des policiers anti-émeutes en feu à
pasto dans le sud ouest de la colombie
transporté à l'hôpital six d'entre eux
ont été victimes de brûlures la police
nationale la police nationale offre ou
50 millions de pesos à toute personne
qui nous aidera à identifier des
personnes qui ont tenté de boue la
russie policier a pas ce qu'est marc
dont votre aide ou les identités et les
traduire en justice à la der à la cause
des incidents violents constatés dans de
nombreuses grandes villes du pays
les raisons de la colère un projet de
réforme fiscale du président ivan duk et
prévoyant notamment d'imposer les
personnes gagnant l'équivalent de plus
de 545 euros par mois alors que le plie
déjà lourdement impacté par la pandémie
de coronavirus le salaire minimum en
colombie n'est que de 206 euros par mois
le produit intérieur brut a chuté de
près de 7% en 2020 et le taux de chômage
dépasser les 18 % en février
mercredi des dizaines de milliers de
colombiens sont descendus dans les rues
pour protester
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je suis venu soutenir les
jeunes qui sont l'espoir de ce pays de
dictature dans la période la plus
corrompue
[Musique]
la programmation l'attaqué de données
j'ai 75 ans et je n'ai jamais vu un
gouvernement aussi corrompu
qu'aujourd'hui face à la pression de la
rue le président ivan bouquet dont le
mandat s'achève en août 2022 annonce
finalement vendredi soir qu'il révisera
son projet le budget familial de base
des colombiens ne sera pas touchée il
n'y aura pas de tva sur les services
publics
il n'y aura pas de tva sur le carburant
entre autres choses les règles du jeu de
la matière que connaît le pays
aujourd'hui ne sont tout simplement pas
modifier l'aspect jonas kehoe les
personnes qui ne paient pas l'impôt sur
le revenu aujourd'hui ne le paieront pas
en d'autres termes l'assiette de l'impôt
sur le revenu ne sera pas élargie
d link ouest order and ce samedi matin
le calme est revenu dans la ville de
cali ou quelques 3000 militaires et
policiers ont été déployés selon un
bilan officiel 209 police y ont été
blessées 185 personnes arrêtées au cours
des manifestations dans tout le pays
une ong fait de son côté état de 46
victimes de violences physiques de la
part de la police dont un mort par balle
arrivé au pouvoir en 2018 la popularité
du président du rrq et n'a depuis cessé
de baisser et s'établit à 33 % selon un
dernier sondage